i am amelia era
i am a famous pilot more than 80 years
after amelia earhart disappeared she
still occupies a place in our
imaginations as a girl and woman people
told me i would not be able to do things
i wanted to do like crying for this
eight-year-old in new jersey amelia
earhart is a badass amelia's mother did
not want her to be just a nice little
girl she listen to her voice it's filled
with the same fearless enthusiasm as
amelia's even shot rats with a gun
suddenly the details of the mystery
vanish the distress calls missing plane
the competing theories the endless
search for evidence they all fall away
and for a few minutes earhart is
embodied and alive before our eyes and
ears
finally understood for who she is not
some lost soul but a powerful and
vibrant person a role model instead of
being scared she was exhilarated she
said
in the earhart family role models are
easy to come by i had the privilege of
traveling to amelia's birthplace in
atchison kansas and speaking to one of
amelia's remarkable descendants amy
kleppner amelia's niece
she was my mother's sister so my aunt
and right away amy kleppner became a
role model for me
i've been looking over your family
history and there seems to be
something amazing about the women in
your family well i'm not sure i'd
describe them
as amazing other than amy earhart
but she was certainly amazing amy
klepner's modesty is typical of the
no-nonsense earhart women i don't think
either my grandmother or my mother
you would not describe them as amazing
amy kleppner recently sailed past her
90th birthday according to her son bram
who you'll hear from in a minute in many
ways her life is as pioneering as her
aunts amy was one of the first women to
earn a phd from columbia university in
philosophy she is strong as energetic as
she was when she hiked half dome in
yosemite on her 63rd birthday
or when she kayaked over 350 miles down
the connecticut river on her 78th
birthday
or when she trekked 100 miles through
great britain when she turned 85. i mean
you get the idea simply put amazing
quite sufficient when you talk to the
earhart family competing disappearance
theories don't really come up instead
you get a chance to talk about amelia
herself a person if they know anything
about amelia earhart what most people
know the extent of it is she flew
airplanes and she disappeared they don't
know anything about her career as a
feminist and her all the work she did to
advance education for girls and women in
women's careers and in gender equality
in this country and i think that's part
of who amelia was that the family is
sort of much more aware than the public
is
bram klepner amelia's great nephew is
describing an amelia earhart that many
people never hear about
when she is re-characterized this way as
a fighter for equality she is no longer
some captive waiting to be rescued from
saipan or the damsel under the red tree
as we heard in the last episode
no because that's not who she really was
to find out what happened to amelia you
don't need to sift through
archaeological evidence on nicomoro so
my relationship to her is like the
relationship of a paleontologist to his
dinosaur and you certainly don't need to
chase down housewives in new jersey the
castaway hypothesis people are at 95
percent the crash in the ocean people
are at 95 percent
on this episode we're going to find out
what happened to amelia by getting to
know her
we're going to rediscover amelia earhart
as the protagonist of her own story a
tremendously capable woman with a very
specific agenda
equality of women first in aviation
equality of women in general equal pay
for equal work the opening of
occupations which women had previously
been barred
that was her agenda and basically she
was fighting for equality
it is this amelia who is mysteriously
missing from almost every version of her
last flight
in fact the remains of amelia earhart
that explorers are searching for are
actually not so hard to find her dna is
everywhere
you just heard a little snippet of her
in the voice of that eight-year-old from
new jersey
what our search today reveals to us
with 100 certainty
is that amelia earhart is still very
much among us
i'm amy briggs executive editor of
national geographic history magazine and
this is overheard at national geographic
a show where we eavesdrop on the wild
conversations we have here at nachio and
follow them to the edges of our big
weird beautiful world
[Music]
on the first episode in our series you
heard about the eight decade mystery
surrounding amelia earhart's
disappearance on this episode we're
charting a new course for amelia one
where she actually completes her
circumnavigation of the globe and
travels all the way into the 21st
century finally as the pilot of her own
narrative more after the break
[Music]
her success has not been won by the
selfish pursuit
of purely personal ambition
but as a part of a career generously
animated
by a wish also to enlarge those
opportunities by expanding the powers of
women
as well as men
in their ever widening limits
this is president herbert hoover in
1932. he's presenting an award to amelia
the nation is proud that an american
woman should be the first woman in
history to fly an airplane across
the atlantic ocean
as their spokesman
i take pride and pleasure
in conferring this
the rarely bestowed medal of the
national geographical society upon mrs
amelia earhart
[Music]
this was only the seventh time this
national geographic special gold medal
had been given to anyone and it was the
first time it was given to a woman
amelia had joined the ranks of commander
robert fury and admiral byrd
the honor for being the first woman to
fly across the atlantic alone i am
deeply grateful
i have no words in which to express my
appreciation
to you
and to the national geographic society
i feel it is too great an honor for my
exploit
in true modest airheart fashion she
insists that it is merely an exploit
history would disagree four years ago i
went on the friendship
and had as has been said was simply a
passenger
in england i was referred to as a sack
of potatoes
that thought has probably
inspired me to try it alone
did you hear her nervous laugh in there
i mean i think that gives something away
a little touch of embarrassment
the friendship that amelia refers to
that's the 1928 friendship flight which
was the first time immediately across
the atlantic in a plane so yes she's
technically the first woman to cross the
atlantic and she became famous for it
but she never flew that plane she sat in
the back a sack of potatoes so it was
said
it was quickly dismissed for what it was
a gimmick and that humiliation became a
defining moment for amelia earhart
it was at that point that she raised the
bar for herself and for others
not only would she refuse to be a mere
passenger ever again she asked women to
do the same for themselves her 1932 solo
flight across the atlantic was a clear
signal that she was no longer interested
in being along for the ride
amelia and her sister muriel got a taste
for adventure at an early age amelia and
muriel's mother
otis
let her kids run around with a rifle and
climb trees and get dirty and do all
sorts of things that
young girls at the time didn't commonly
do
but she herself had been
one of the first women to make it to the
top of pike's peak in colorado
it certainly shows a certain amount of
physical courage and adventurousness and
and so forth
like her mother before her amelia
developed a passion for taking risks
even as a very young girl in atchison
atchison was a sleepy town on the
missouri river she was surrounded by
cousins first cousins second cousins
thirds cousins
susan butler who wrote east to the dawn
a seminal biography on earhart you
should pick it up if you're interested
interviewed many of those cousins
including one named catch chalice catch
recalled how they acted out many wild
adventures one of them was based on a
mythical poem called atalanta and
caledon it was amelia's favorite
it was a poem about a warrior woman a
mythological woman who
saved her kingdom by arming herself and
killing the boar that was
menacing the kingdom she said that
emilia had memorized it as a child and
it was so important to amelia that she
memorized it
at atlanta the warrior woman vowed to
remain unmarried at all costs and that
went for amelia too it was one risk she
wasn't willing to take
amelia had decided at a very young age
she was never going to get married or at
least she if she did get married she
wasn't going to be a stay-at-home
obedient mom she was going to have a
life of her own of purpose and action
amelia's young adult life was filled
with finding that purpose in action she
left home in search of adventure working
as a nurse during world war one in
canada
there she got to know a new group of
adventurers aviators and her lifelong
fascination with flying began
she took her first plane ride in 1920 in
long beach california and started taking
flying lessons with another aviatrix ned
a snook isn't that the best name
before long emilia had set her first
record reaching 14 000 feet she broke
the women's altitude record it was pure
thrill
she would go on to break a dozen more
records for distance speed altitude she
even bested herself
she had never thought of it as a
profession she just thought it was a
great deal of fun
but in 1924 amelia's parents divorced
her family's financial instability and
her father's alcoholism something he had
battled for years forced amelia to move
to boston where she helped to support
her mother and sister she'd been
studying to be a doctor
and she didn't really have the money to
become a doctor
school was no longer an option for
amelia so she had to go to work
once in boston she dedicated herself to
life as a settlement house worker what
today we'd call a social worker where
she worked to help new immigrants adjust
to life in the u.s
settlement housework was
definitely a very
progressive and
respectable
profession tj busso is professor of
women's gender and sexuality studies at
purdue university she describes how
amelia's agenda early on was geared
towards working on behalf of others
she made sure of that and i admire her
for that for making sure that her life
had a meaning that went beyond herself
although amelia continued to fly
airplanes while working at denison house
in boston she did it on the side and
even as her notoriety grew the social
work stayed with her according to susan
butler it was her passion if anything
she was obsessed with being a social
worker she took her as her role in life
the fact that she should act as an agent
for social change for women so amelia
had found her niche by the time that she
was picked to be a passenger on the
friendship flight
see there's that friendship flight again
the sitting in the back seat sack of
potatoes flight in 1928.
amelia was chosen from a short list of
female pilots for this flight by george
palmer putnam an american publisher and
promoter extraordinaire
hot on the heels of charles lindbergh's
transatlantic 1927 flight which was huge
putnam was eager to feed the public's
appetite for airplanes which was growing
more ravenous with every new record
broken
so putnam set his sights on amelia and
surprisingly the feeling was mutual
with a business partner like george
putnam by her side emilia found herself
with opportunities and with those
opportunities came influence even though
the friendship flight was kind of lame
it did send emilia in a new direction
she could finally do things that women
and very few men had done it was a
personal revolution and as a
revolutionary she'd have the chance to
confront some very old ways of thinking
so there's still the idea that that is
really rife in the late 19th century
that women's
reproductive organs are are attached to
their intellectual capacities so that if
they strain themselves either physically
or they strain themselves intellectually
with too much education or or too much
learning you know that this will
impede their ability to reproduce to
become mothers
the antidote to this very backwards
mindset
flying with one deaf move amelia started
changing minds about what women could do
and sure there was still skepticism but
it is
far outweighed
by just public
excitement
for
her ascending to the heavens similar to
becoming an astronaut i would say there
was nothing that was more
symbolic of being modern of being
empowered of being
free and of being heroic
than flying
the adventure that amelia sought was the
adventure that came with finding new
paths to equality for women and that was
uncharted territory at the time she
really was a feminist there's no doubt
in my mind about that
amelia had planted a seed of what gender
equality could look like and the seed
began to sprout quickly along with her
popularity
1928 was dubbed the year of the woman by
the press
we had won the right to vote eight years
earlier but the 1928 presidential
election was the first time that women
were expected to have real influence on
the outcome by the time the welcome home
parades were over for amelia's
friendship flight herbert hoover was
elected
ah hoover
many women including amelia had high
hopes for the guy expecting him to push
through progressive new legislation
including the equal rights amendment and
guess what didn't happen
emilia met with hoover hoping to rally
him to the cause the words she said to
him in 1932 may sound all too familiar
mr hoover i know from practical
experience of discrimination that
confront women when they enter an
occupation where men have priority in
opportunity advancement and protection
that's the voice of diana trujijo as
amelia earhart diana knows all about
occupations where men have priority and
opportunity she's an aerospace engineer
at nasa's jet propulsion laboratory
diana is a superstar in an
overwhelmingly male-dominated field she
is one of the mission leads in nasa's
perseverance mars rover
talk about a badass you're going to hear
dionna reading amelia's words today
that's because she's part of amelia's
aeronautic legacy diana came to the u.s
from kali colombia at 17 with 300 under
pocket a knack for math and relentless
ambition
need proof of amelia's dna being all
around us just look at diana's hard one
against all odds accomplishments in this
field it's that dna that makes women
fight to be taken seriously and to be
treated as equals
oh and in case you're wondering amelia's
conversation with herbert hoover back in
1932 that didn't move the needle for
women legislatively speaking whatsoever
that change would have to come from
elsewhere
but then
wouldn't you know it something happened
that would change amelia's outlook
forever
more after the break
[Music]
it appears that george putnam fell madly
in love with amelia earhart
love
a trap that amelia had vowed she would
never fall into was suddenly staring her
in the face
from every
bit of evidence we have it appears that
he
absolutely loved her and wanted to see
her succeed for herself as well as you
know
for his own his own career purposes
um and
agreed to all of the conditions that she
laid out when she married him
the conditions
well the conditions presented by amelia
were pretty hardcore even by today's
standards
on the morning of their wedding this is
the letter she gave him dear gpp
there are some things that should be
read before we are married things we
have talked over before you must know
again my reluctance to marry
i feel the move just now as foolish as
anything i could do i must exact a cruel
promise and that is you will let me go
in a year if we find no happiness
together i will try to do my best in
every way and give you that part of me
you know and seem to want
ae
well
now that's what i call a prenup these
are not the words of a starry-eyed
blushing bride
they're the sentiments of someone trying
to avoid how she saw marriage as a
confinement
and as if that weren't enough
the letter further details that amelia
and gpp should both be free to see other
people and not adhere to what she called
quote any medieval code of faithfulness
unquote
they would keep everything private and
away from public scrutiny
when amelia drew that line in the sand
it was her way of remembering her inner
warrior from her childhood the huntress
at atlanta whom she had aspired to be
she makes it clear in her personal
papers that
she loves him to a point and the point
was
uh the limit on her own personal freedom
and she was not willing to go beyond it
i i just think that's that that sells
volumes
emilia and gpp's marriage did not get in
the way of her freedom far from it he
worked tirelessly on her behalf and
together they put the naysayers to rest
because the very next flight she took
was crossing the atlantic this time
flying solo when she proved herself in
1932 with a transatlantic flight that
she herself piloted
and after that that kind of
condescension and patriotizing tone
grew far more mute
[Music]
and amelia's career was launched into
the stratosphere
she became a worldwide celebrity which
gave her a megaphone and access to power
she
did a lot of political work using her
celebrities to gain access to the white
house to eleanor roosevelt to
make the public aware that an era and
rights for women in general had not been
fully achieved by the achievement of
suffrage amelia's friendship with
eleanor roosevelt was legendary in 1933
amelia reportedly cut short a stuffy
dinner party at the white house and the
two of them took a flight to baltimore
and back
all while wearing evening gowns
things had changed for the kid from
atchison susan butler explains she was
sort of oprah winfrey gloria steinem all
rolled into one george palmer putnam had
her booked all over the united states in
1936 she made 136 lectures
criss-crossing the country she had two
messages her message when she was
talking to mixed men and women was to
promote flying but when she was talking
to women's groups she was promoting
careers for women
amelia had a knack for crafting her
public persona
and writing her own story
and that even included attempting to
maintain control of her name
which wasn't easy
dear mr solzberger
she wrote to the publisher of the new
york times
may i make a request of the times
through you despise the mild expression
of my wishes and those of gpp i'm
constantly referred to as mrs putman
when the times mention me in his column
i admit that i have no principle to
uphold when i ask for my professional
naming print however it is for many
reasons more convenient for both of us
to be called amelia earhart
her request seems reasonable enough by
today's standards but at the time most
married women did not keep their birth
names in fact taking their husband's
name was practically forced upon them
legally
and so
even though she was widely known as the
most famous aviatrix whose birth name
undoubtedly helped sell many copies of
the new york times
back then her request would fall on deaf
ears
as a change maker amelia's carefully
constructed image had everything to do
with freedom and having it as a woman
so for instance she's the first female
celebrity to have her own line of
luggage
although luggage might not seem like a
progressive product in the 1930s it was
and what's the most important piece of
luggage in that line of luggage was the
weekender back and it's meant to hold
cosmetics and a change of clothes and
some underwear
and some toiletries
for a couple of days
a woman with a weekender bag was able to
travel without a trunk
which meant without a man to carry it
which meant that she would be able to
move about as she pleased
tj busso considers the weakener bag to
be a symbol of a kind of sexual
revolution
she meant that in a very serious way
to convey her commitment to women's
sexual liberation that they could sleep
with whomever they chose they could go
wherever they chose
that is one radical piece of luggage
emilia's encouragement of women to push
to excel to resist definition was
relentless by forging ahead on her own
terms she created paths that women could
follow
and the way that she reached the women
she wanted to influence was always going
to be tied to the thing that she was
known for
being a pilot which was perhaps the most
audacious feat of all
because it carried so much symbolic
weight
we do keep having to remind ourselves
and the public at large and the next
generation
that what was really remarkable about
her is what it meant
to be a pilot in that period of time and
that it meant something more than really
just
flying a plane
amelia understood this of course
even though she often said she flew
planes for the fun of it she was more
aware than any one of the dangers
involved
she seemed to understand that one day
the risks she took to advance women's
equality would get the best of her
it's no coincidence that professor
boisseau was the inaugural amelia
earhart faculty in residence at purdue
university i'm sort of in the ground
zero of amelia earhart fandom here at
purdue
amelia has had fans at purdue for
decades she was invited there in 1935 as
a lecturer and advisor
see many young female students in
universities back then they would go to
college work hard and then
spend the rest of their lives taking
care of their husbands and children
the so-called mrs degree
and we all know how amelia felt about
that
so her time at purdue was spent advising
young women how to have careers instead
i mean can you imagine having amelia
earhart as your advisor how inspiring
would that be
ultimately amelia saw this job as an
opportunity believe it or not to get out
of flying and settle into a desk job
according to amelia's niece amy klebner
amelia was ready for life as a civilian
i think that really would have been what
she wanted to do had she returned from
that flight she said she was going to
retire from long distance flying she
really enjoyed very much the time she
spent at purdue purdue was very
enthusiastic about her work there
in fact amelia said as much herself in
1937 as she prepared for her final epic
journey she wrote this
here was shining adventure beckoning
with new experiences adding knowledge of
flying of people of myself i felt that
with the flying behind me that would be
more useful to me into the program we
planned at purdue
then two there was my belief that now
and then women should do for themselves
what men have already done and
occasionally what men have not done
thereby establishing themselves as
persons and perhaps encouraging other
women towards greater independence of
thought and action
in the end emilia was an earhart through
and through her urge for independence
required taking risks it was a part of
the family's imperative
so what do you think it is about amelia
earhart that inspires so much passion
excitement or obsession
in the larger world
well i think it was the spirit of
adventure that really distinguished her
that she was a strong independent woman
now
popular culture is much more accepting
of strong independent women
than it was
i've got to say emmy klepner really
nails it there we are much more
accepting of strong independent women
now and why because of women like amelia
earhart
i think she's the most important role
model for young american women well
that's really interesting why why do you
give her that position well because
every time that i was giving talks on
amelia earhart after i wrote the book i
found young women all over the united
states emailing me about how important
she was she simply had a wonderful life
and she spent her time trying to get
women to become more independent and
take more responsibility for themselves
over the course of speaking with so many
people about the story of amelia earhart
i found that there were people who
deeply admire amelia's political legacy
the one that has to do with equality
they see it as one that continues
despite the fact that she tragically
went missing
then there is another group of people
the searchers of amelia who look at her
legacy quite differently
when i asked rick gillespie a castaway
theory proponent who we heard from in
the last episode about how amelia would
feel about the searching he said this
she would love the attention she'd love
it amelia always wanted to feel special
but there is something that separates
the second group from the first
something rather obvious once you see it
searches are all men
yeah it's a really interesting question
i never thought about it before but it
is true the searchers are is it 100 do
we know any female searchers
i don't know any female searches
not a one the searchers are all men
wow
are the searchers responsible for
keeping amelia story alive
perhaps
but despite their efforts it's unlikely
albeit possible that another expedition
will reveal a satisfying end to this
mystery
i hope the media earhart is found no
matter where she is
susan butler is on to something there
the last chapter of this tantalizing
whodunit didn't take place near a tiny
pacific atoll or the deep waters
surrounding it
amelia's legacy exists along a very
different line of position
she's much closer than you think
in fact the final indisputable clues of
where to find amelia exist somewhere
inside her own story
in her own words
the flight has added nothing to aviation
after all literally hundreds have
crossed the atlantic by air if we count
those who have gone heavier than that
when amelia received that national
geographic gold medal from herbert
hoover she made her case to women in no
uncertain terms
i hope
that the flight has meant something to
women in aviation and it may not have
been obvious to the men in the audience
if it had i should feel it justified
this piece of evidence has been
overlooked and unexamined for decades
but i can't claim anything else
the modesty of her sentiment like the
earhart women who came before and after
her says volumes
did amelia's work mean something to
women in aviation diana trujido answers
that question definitively her work at
nasa's jet propulsion laboratory is a
direct extension of a history that
amelia helped to build
and still has implications for the
future but if that brings us to 95
certainty we find ourselves continuing
to ask the question how do we get to 100
the final chapter of the earhart mystery
contains one last clue to her
whereabouts
before amelia set off on her fateful
round-the-world flight she gave her
husband another letter
this time it was only to be opened if
she did not return
in a hard-to-read chicken scratch which
may have been hastily scribbled down
given the thousands of things she had to
prepare for before she took off
here's what she wrote to him
please know i am quite aware of the
hazards of the trip
i want to do it because i want to do it
women must try to do things as men have
tried when they fail their achievements
must be but a challenge to others
this sentiment belonged to amelia
but it also belongs to me
and to so many millions of others
now more than 80 years later we can
thank our ability to choose a career and
education whether or not we marry
what we are called heck even what
luggage we buy as challenges that were
accepted by the multitudes who believe
as much as amelia did
inequality
her legacy being reignited and pushed
forward by new amelia's all the time is
not lost at sea awaiting discovery
now
i'd say it's alive and well
and inside of all of us
if you like what you hear and want to
support more content like this please
rate and review us in your podcast app
and consider a national geographic
subscription that's the best way to
support overheard
go to nacheo.com backslash explore to
subscribe
take a gander at the gorgeous brown
suede jacket amelia wore during her 1932
transatlantic crossing by heading over
to the amelia earhart archive at purdue
university luckily it's all online
and yes there are images of her
revolutionary luggage there too
you can visit amelia's childhood home in
atchison kansas it's now the amelia
earhart museum it was a highlight for me
as i learned about her story but you can
also visit the website
all this and more can be found in our
show notes they're right there on your
podcast app
this week's overheard episode is
produced by marcy thompson our producers
are kyrie douglas and alana strauss
our senior producers are brian gutierrez
and jacob pinter
a big special shout out and thank you to
my fellow searchers melissa faris
kristen clark and janae west
our senior editor is eli chen our
manager of audio is carla wills our
executive producer of audio is davar
ardellan who also edited this episode
our fact checkers are robin palmer and
julie beer our photo editor is julie
howe
ted woods sound designed this episode
and hansdale sue composed our theme
music
this podcast is a production of national
geographic partners
whitney johnson is the director of
visuals and immersive experiences
david brindley is national geographic's
interim editor-in-chief and i'm your
host amy briggs thanks for listening and
see y'all next time
[Music]
[Music]
you